also ich finde mich sehen man wirklich
mehr aus wie mädchen als jungen
oder die ganzen teile alter sie haben
hatte ich schon gesprochen wird dass
kein komischer typ da ich glaube die mir
leid mich hier weil ich so hässlich aus
der besonders schöne freundin und die
haben mich wirklich ausgelassen ja und
ich habe mich komplett zu klären also
hier kann man es sehen meine haare
gerade extrem kurz aber dunkle haare ich
hoffe aber dass du noch mal ach ja
stimmen zu ehrlich was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen zwei einem neuen
video ja ich hab natürlich euch geht es
gut wir haben gerade halb acht oder so
und heute startet ein ganz besonderes
video ich bin letztens irgendwann mal
auf die idee gekommen und zwar gibt es
hier eine menge mädels also ich kann da
auf eine oder zwei die oftmals
extensions tragen also halt so
haarverlängerung haaransatz das halt
komplett die frisur anders aussieht
das hört sich jetzt wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen verrückt an aber ich hab dann
so gedacht gibt es das eigentlich auch
für jungs und dann hab ich mal gegoogelt
und wenn auch irgendwas gestoßen also
war so massiv dass man leute wenn man
hier oben ein gibt extensions männer
genau da wird mir hier dieses angezeigt
toupet für männer echthaar extensions to
b herren pony haarteil haarverlängerung
was auch immer eigentlich kennt man ja
so extensions hersteller können
eigentlich kann man ja extensions so
dass man die halt ins haar macht eine
längere haare hat das war so zumindest
mein und definition davon aber
extensions sind auch wenn man halt
komplett so so echte haare sich
praktisch komplett über kopf macht ne
mäßig perücke diese steht dann da
extensions heute schreibt mir gerne mal
die genaue definition in die kommentare
aber hier kann man sich ja sehen
echthaar extensions das habe ich
bestellt weil ich wollte auch mal
extensions tragen einfach um zu sehen
wie reagieren menschen darauf fällt das
bei mir auf oder fällt überhaupt nicht
auf und deswegen habe ich mir dieses
paket bestellt ist das jetzt schon
aufgegangen
nein ich habe nur meinen hier ach so
genau ich habe dir aber in blond
bestellt übrigens hier kann man schon
sehen weil schwarz war mir irgendwie ein
bisschen so das passt nicht zu mir
heute startet der 24 stunden blog ich
muss dir jetzt sage ich trage ich
natürlich beim schlafen ich meine das
ist mir auch ein bisschen zu dumm zählt
man einfach nur so ein paar reactions so
von leuten draus und der generell wir
werden jetzt in die stadt gehen also es
handelt sich um echte haare das heißt
rein theoretisch könntest du dir auch
ein bisschen gleiche mich schneiden
damit dass so ein bisschen echte
aussieht weiß er kann sein dass das halt
überhaupt nicht zu mir passt leute wie
geht das mal kurz ins bad wo ich das
ding raus also es fühlt sich wirklich
gut an und keine ahnung wem diese haare
bewerten schießt danke ich frage mich
jetzt gerade vodafone und wo hinten ist
ich habe mir das eigentlich vor allem
also vorgestellt wie das aussehen könnte
weil ich hatte halt auch schon mal
selber blonde haare und die sind jetzt
voll struppig deswegen also soll ein big
three rüberkommen nicht so reich wenn
ich jetzt heute karneval feiern wollen
würde
und sparen sich aus dieser nils
holgersson oder
[Musik]
ich verstehe jetzt fordern hinten ist
also ich finde mich jetzt mal so schaut
da geht das auf jeden fall absolut klar
nur soweit überhaupt nicht weil ich
finde ich sinnvoll weil ich aus damit
die haben sind irgendwie fiel zufällig
und das passt gar nicht zu reden gesicht
ich dachte wirklich dass es eigentlich
echt gut aussehen könnte so ist sowieso
absolute volksgruppe also ich finde ich
sehe wirklich mehr aus wie mädchen als
jungen oder also gehe ich auch kein
zuhause oder man glaubt das müsste auch
hier besser fern weil ich bin auch so
unzufrieden also du musst jetzt bei
welchen auch wirklich extrem abschneiden
ok und dann geht das global aber so was
kann doch kein mensch tragen der ist
halt wirklich ernst meine nein ich habe
doch extra für männer ein gegeben dass
ich mich mal an aber das sieht viel
besser aus bei dir ich warte mal also
ich kann das jetzt wirklich nicht
schlecht du siehst du siehst es ganz
anders aus wie ein ganz anderer typ so
leute schreibt man eine bewertung von 1
bis 10 in den kommentare wie ihr diese
friese steht das ist aber wirklich eine
für männer hier genau das hier ist das
in blond so musst du auf jeden fall ein
foto machen ohne spaß oder leute hier
steht bei instagram name da müsst ihr
auf jeden fall mal das foto leiden was
du da jetzt posten also ich finde das
sommer neuer schreibt mal wie findet ihr
meine neuen haare weil das video kommt
erst morgen und dann können wir das ja
so weiß ja dann checkt das keiner okay
jetzt möchte ich aber trotzdem sind sie
eigentlich mehr haare für männer dass du
mir die mal kurz ein bisschen schneidet
so wie ich selber rat aus hier würde ich
mich gar nicht mehr zeigen deswegen
schneit du dir jetzt mal kürzer und dann
seht ihr gleich wie es danach aussieht
aber so geht nirgendwo hin
es ist noch nichts aber es schneit
übernahm hans das mich wieder an
[Musik]
ich finde eigentlich mal ganz so
schlecht kann man ja ich will hier unten
noch das geile zeit dass man hier ein
wirklich seine weisheit echt zurück oder
ich finde es gar nicht mal so schlecht
jetzt also wirklich auf meint tut so
nicht leute und ich muss auch ehrlich
sagen ich hab natürlich eigentlich vor
dass man ja halt nur meine haare sieht
also dass ich keine camp ausziehen muss
nur da wirklich niemand ernst das sieht
einfach nur scheiße ist ja gesehen und
so geht es wenigstens noch ein bisschen
ich glaube das liegt auch nur daran war
ich mich nur mit meinen anderen herren
kennen und so eigentlich gar nicht
deswegen schreibt eure machen dazu in
die kommentare sieht halt ein bisschen
weiblich aus und ich ansonsten nils
holgersson ist ein gutes stichwort
ansonsten ist okay wir freuen uns dass
es nun einfach mal gucken was passiert
wäre sie gerade weibliche aus ich oder
du ich mache es mal so ein noch so so
dass ich so richtig cool vielgereiste
aber das lustige ist halt dass es so gar
nicht passt nur an äußerlichen oder
[Musik]
sogleich wir sind da noch mal kurz
checken dass man hier auch nix ja okay
ich bin bereit
so leute haben
jetzt hier in unseren platz also bisher
als nächstes passiert marie sagt die
ganze zeit sowie fall nicht wie
kleinlich aber eigentlich kaum
aufgefallen 12 sekunden später okay
leute ich werde so dumm an gekürzt schon
hat die ganzen teile alter die haben hat
sich schon herumgesprochen so dass das
ein komisches licht da ich glaube die
mir leid mich hier weil ich so hässlich
aussieht aber sondern schöne freundin
habe
[Musik]
jülich
es war wirklich die diva sowie ist die
hat sich die ganze zeit zu ihrem gerät
jetzt sogar die die mädchen sind mit
ihrem freund runde lag wirklich die
saßen auf einer bank und die hat die
ganze zulegen wird
also ich hätte eigentlich darauf
gewettet dass es so eigentlich niemandem
auffällt aber die kellner habe mich
schon extrem angeguckt die ganze zeit
also ich würde schon heftig angeschafft
und die haben mich wirklich ausgelacht
ja und ich habe nicht komplett so kommt
ja also ich nenne jetzt auch keine möbel
so verschlechtert sich der andere
kellner umgedrehten das kann es ja nicht
machen
stell dir vor das hören heute meine
echten habe das mädchen hat einfach die
ganze zeit wir bauen immer geguckt ich
kann es heute schwer einschätzen weil
die halt wirklich ganz einem
rumknutschen waren was erwachsene nicht
machen würden aber die sagten schon
relativ erwachsen aus so ich glaube die
war so 22 21 22 und hat wirklich die
ganze zeit so alex immer gut und leute
das beste am ganzen abend findet diese
bonbons jemand einmal bekommt dann
morgen leute was geht ab schönen guten
nächsten tag also wir haben schon so
heute samstag genau ich muss sagen ich
habe von vornherein gesagt das macht ja
auch niemand also ich hab damit jetzt
nicht geschlafen war so ich habe jetzt
allerdings wieder aufgezogen und
irgendwie finde ich jetzt schon dass es
gar nicht mehr
ich weiß nicht natürlich dieses immer
noch komisch aus aber wenn man mich
jetzt überhaupt nicht kennt dann ist das
jetzt auch so halt nicht dass man denkt
okay das ist jetzt auf jeden fall nicht
seine wichtige friese so wollte jetzt
noch einkaufen gehen weil das sehr
wichtig morgen des sonntag und da kann
man nicht einkaufen kann wenn man das
jetzt so sieht das sieht doch ganz klar
aus wie einfach so eine friese von 2012
die totale justin bieber frisur 2012
oder wann auch immer das war schade doch
ich gehe heute auch ohne cap wir gehen
uns einkaufen ich habe mir eigentlich
gedacht vielleicht mache ich mal so ein
undercut oder sting ist wenn man hier
die haare hochzeit kann man direkt an
moment ihrer kasse den ansatz sehen
und das wollen wir nicht ich spreche
jetzt ein bisschen glatt damit teil noch
wie darüber kommen und dann sehen wir
uns gleich im supermarkt das fragt mich
ob ich der wollte eigentlich dass diese
perücke wenigstens ein bisschen mehr
aussieht kommunistin war so teuer und
wenn ihr wirklich vor wiese und bing
haben tragen wollen dann bestellt euch
nicht die die ich euch gezeigt habe weil
kurz das war's das ist eine echthaar
extensions der muskel stars hin
ok einkaufen plus eine sache die man
auch sagen muss die haare übertrieben
denn geld also der deformierte nicht so
auf silber shampoo benutzt was guckst du
so laut erst jetzt einkaufen hier
aldi süd ich dachte eigentlich wären wir
aldi nord also ich finde ich sehr
richtig gut aus ich tue jetzt einfach
die kappe aber nicht kannst du dir was
so gesagt konzentrieren wo alkohol das
ist immer gut wenn ich so wir kaufen
würde die würden safe meinen ausweis
sehen wollen
chiquita bananen brauchen wir
also ich muss sagen bis jetzt hat sich
noch niemand doch mal angeguckt ja
komisch finde ich nicht was ist denn
[Musik]
ja egal hier ist aus davos guthaben wenn
ich die das keiner so weit weg ist wer
guckt mich jedenfalls oben heißt du na
ja das sieht so oft wenn just
wahrscheinlich hat die frau sind haben
wir doch die hübsche blonde haben nicht
richtiger schwede krise plant schon bist
du leute jetzt mal ohne spaß seid
richtig ehrlich wenn ihr mich jetzt
nicht kennen würden weil es das einzige
diese perücke war nicht günstig und
viele leute wollen so was natürlich auch
tragen und das soll nicht auffallen
meiner meinung nach ist eine absolute
katastrophe weil die wirklich überhaupt
nicht sitzt vielleicht liegt das auch an
mir keine ahnung vielleicht steht die
anderen menschen besser aber wenn ihr
mich jetzt nicht kennen würden oder
vielleicht leute die jetzt gerade zum
ersten mal mich sehen findet ihr das
sieht authentische aus oder absolut
fähig weil ich bin der meinung 100%
einfach fake oder ja naja bis später
leute das geht
wir haben jetzt bis samstagabend 18 uhr
oder so ich habe das video hier schon
soweit eigentlich fertig geschnitten und
es geht schon zwölf minuten um ehrlich
zu sein kommt das auch gut hin ich meine
wir haben gestern abend damit angefangen
ja so krass fiel mir jetzt auch nicht
gemacht natürlich könnten wir jetzt noch
dahingehend dahingehend fürs video aber
keine ahnung also es war schon
interessant genug und naja ich glaube
jetzt im nachhinein wirklich dass leute
die mich absolut ich kennen sich
vielleicht denken der hat aber viele
haare und so also so viel volumen darin
aber ob man das jetzt merkt weiß ich
nicht also gestern abend im restaurant
wurde ich auf jeden fall von den
kellnern ausgelacht kann man so sagen
also ohne spaß das war krass heute beim
einkaufen meiner meinung nach gar nicht
weiß nicht schreibt eure meinung in die
kommentare wie fandet ihr soll das aus
und vor allem auch weitere ideen was ich
noch machen könnte also so in diese
richtung war auf jeden fall ganz lustig
jetzt kann ich an alle jungs sagen
extensions lohnt sich nicht das war es
von mir
ich hoffe dass sie dadurch gefallen
abonniert den kanal
doch nach oben instagram profil ab 30
alex wie haut rein
[Musik]